it's funny for me normally when we're
filming you know after we've done
something climbed up or crossed a river
or eaten something terrible the crew
always like oh god okay great can't keep
moving this time i remember finishing it
and you know i went okay guys we're done
and just look in the mall maybe just
like
yeah
this is not right
which is an arguable point
okay here we go
here we
go here we go
we're see moved by his own admission as
a city guy we were in northern canada
wintertime short days super cold
temperatures
bad weather we had that day as well high
winds by this stage
we'd also he'd spend a night out with me
uh who's hand slept who's starving it's
freezing cold so you're on kind of
you're on the back foot already you know
and then i think to ask somebody to
strip down to their underpants and get
into freezing water is a big leap this
is a test that the british royal marine
commandos do they strip down oh then
they have to get in the water they have
to keep calm
but here's the thing once we're in there
we're on a ticking time you know you've
got minutes really before you start to
lose all sense of not only be able to
think naturally but also be able to move
your fingers and your hands so once
we're in we've got to work really fast
when i suggested this to simu he was a
bit like he looked at me like
no i
what really and uh and i said well we'll
plan it we'll get a fire going we'll
have a system because the important
thing is to make sure when you get out
and you're that cold
you've got systems in place ultimately
to save your life you know if you get
out of that water with wet clothes and
no fly in that's that sort of
environment you're dead you know
genuinely so we had to get it right and
to see moves credit
once he kind of got in and we're going
to do this he was like come on and you
could see the adrenaline build in him
and he was amazing you know he just
didn't hesitate got in there was
definitely that hyperventilating of
panic but we did it together and it cut
he calmed himself down and you know at
the end of that show i thought respect
you know that that's you're right on the
edge there
look this is you know what that is look
like an octopus no that's that's
that's placenta
well somebody had a baby first of all
shaq what a legend of a guy such a live
wire such a talent such a entrepreneur
so such a cool guy but also huge you
know and we'd never taken a guess this
big before and i remember we were trying
to uh deck him out in the right gear you
know and the only gloves we could find
were oven mitts you know the oven gloves
massive great things we had shack like
this and we were climbing i'd be
climbing up this cliff with him and on
the top there we just saw it on the
ground a placenta you know it's huge
something big had just given birth and
all was left was this bloody sack of
whatever you know flu is and everything
and more than likely it's going to be a
moose in those that part of the states
were in up in the forest there and it
was fresh you know you could smell it i
mean if nature tells you if it's off you
go near it you know pretty quickly it's
off i mean look at that
yeah let's go
actually it's good i mean it's like like
with blood you know it's
true survival food you know it's there
for a purpose that placenta is feeding
that young moose perfectly so in terms
of nutrients and energy density
you don't get much better than placenta
but you just have to kind of get your
head around the thing and try and kind
of shut that part of it out it's
important for me to get always been
running well get the guests involved you
know get them gutting the fish or
whatever i got shaq to cut that placenta
he was a bit like oh you know but it's
um cyclo life and if you're gonna eat it
gotta help
this could be lethal quicksand it's been
known to swallow people and vehicles
whole
we've set this up so i can show you how
to get out of it alive this actually
this clip was from one of the first ever
episodes of man vs wild when we were
still kind of winging it in every way
and trying to figure out kind of things
and we'd come across this quicksand and
our default is that will you avoid the
obstacles and then we were just figuring
out actually man versus what is about
let's find the obstacles and let's make
something of it and let's let's show
show what you do if you got called in it
and like with all sharing knowledge the
best ways explanation demonstration
imitation you know as they used to say
in the military in other words get in
get involved show what you're doing show
how you get out of it and what's nasty
about this stuff
is the more you fight it
the more like pulls you in
and let you suddenly realize it's not
just this crust the sand that you
thought but actually it's all of
that
clay and water i remember this the way
to go out to where you came in don't
plow on and then don't fight it stay
calm and try and get one limb up gently
at a time try and get yourself on top of
this stuff rather than in it and then
just wriggle gently like a seal spread
your weight and get back to safety
okay lunch here we go look at this and
now this is for real i found this on the
riverbank okay so don't freak out too
much
i think the president looked a little
surprised when i pulled out this sort of
bloody carcass of half-eaten salmon
normally we're running wild we we reach
out to people this is one of the few
ones where the guests came to us it just
happened to be a sitting president kind
of a lot of our production crew and
myself included almost didn't believe it
i remember our producer dell he got a
call from the white house saying that uh
obama was going to alaska he wanted to
see some of the effects of climate
change close up he was a fan of running
wild
would would i do a show with him before
we knew it i was kind of stood on that
riverbank suddenly getting really
nervous
secret service everywhere snipers in the
mountains helicopters doing final sweeps
of the area waiting for the president to
appear out of the the forest and
definitely a life moment bear hey mr
president how you doing how do you do
sir good to see you sir i'm back how are
you yeah it's wonderful to meet you in
so many ways running wild is like an
adventure extended interview but it goes
deep so you're getting to really know
people well because you're out there for
two days and you're facing a few fears
and you're tired and scared at times and
you're sleeping out and you're around a
fire so you get to know the real person
people's stories tell themselves if you
give it the space
and i always think the real star of
running wild is actually the wild and
for me the the highlight really was just
getting to hear his
as a man as a guy rather than as a
president and to hear him just talking
about
his his girls you know his daughters and
his hopes and aspirations and
everyday stuff that you'd maybe
want to ask somebody in the position as
the most powerful man in the world
rather than just about politics and
situations and countries and actually
afterwards he said bring the family to
the white house uh which we did a few
months later and i was much more nervous
then because suddenly everyone's in
suits and looking smart and suddenly
you're into that machine for the family
it was amazing to get to go you know to
the white house president obama had us
in the oval office we had kind of tea
together in a way the cool bit though
was at the end because
there was a incident on capitol hill at
the same time was a breach of security
and we were having tea and we were kind
of getting near the end anyway and
suddenly the marines came in and said
sir we need to move now. even the
president was going okay what's
happening you know he got taken that way
we got taken that way and we had the
marines escorted as we went into this
room we were sealed in this room for a
bid and then we went down through the
situation room and out the back entrance
to the white house and and afterwards
our boys were pretty young and i said
what was the best bit and they went
the evacuation of course you know
okay are you ready yeah one two three
okay one more one more one two three
ready push slide sliding oh boy
wait yeah oh my god so this was with
natalie in the in the desert in the
canyons as you know moving through
canyons dynamic
difficult slow pace because you're
moving along and suddenly there's a huge
drop and you can't
jump across it we're gonna do something
that's called a rope transfer okay you
kind of repel down the first line okay
and then you pull the other line
and then you transfer your kind of
weight and then you pull yourself out
that one i'd actually pre-set up a loose
rope line across this because otherwise
we'd never be able to do this the
problem with doing a one rope is that
technically it's not really classified
as safe because all your tension is down
and a rope strength is that way you can
do these transfers like this but really
you want two plus ropes on it if you're
going to have a lot of weight on it so i
thought well why don't we try a
different technique which is an old
mountain rescue technique for crossing
crevasses and getting gear across is
called a rope transfer and instead of
just having a tight line you repel down
and then when the slap comes you pull
that up
clip onto that one transfer whilst
you're sort of on it still and then
jumer up and ascend up the other rope
you know natalie's smart she wanted to
be pushed but it was one of those things
that you kind of got to do it on your
own you know we're like grapes when you
squeeze this you see what we're made of
and
you never really know how someone's
going to react until they're in it and
she was amazing
i'm on a raft in the pacific ocean i've
collected some fresh water but it's full
of bird droppings and it's rancid drink
this and you'd probably vomit and risk
worsening dehydration but there is a way
of using it to gain life-giving fluids
but only as a last resort i'm gonna give
myself an enema well when you're doing
uh
survival on rafts you got limited
limited number of things you can do it's
not like being in a jungle we can climb
this and cross these rivers and i knew
this great survival story where this
family had their their boat hit by a
whale and it started sinking they end up
in the life rafters family the mum was a
nurse they had two young kids and the
dad they ran out of all their supplies
they'd caught a few turtles and some
fish they had rain water but it was all
in the bottom of the life raft it was
fettered and
mixed with turtle innards and rain water
and but the nurse knew that if she could
get
fluids into all of them
rectally you know i threw an enema
it would hydrate them without making
them sick and she did that and actually
it saved her children's life and i tied
the raft with a bunch of old hosings so
i had some hoes i had a water bottle my
water bottle and you know i tried to
jerry-rig this thing up where you know i
could uh perform an enema and it was one
of the
moments of my life least comfortable
moments least pleasant moments
probably not to be repeated by
performing an enema you bypass the gag
reflex rehydrating your body without the
risk of vomiting hey it worked and it's
funny for me normally when we're filming
you know after we've done something
climbed up or crossed the river or eaten
something terrible the crew always like
oh god okay great can't keep moving this
time i remember finishing it
and you know i went okay guys we're done
and just look at them all maybe just
like
yeah
this is not right
which is an arguable point but the real
point is it is right and it could save
your life so
you never know
let's hope it doesn't come to that i
guess all you do is lie back
i think of england i'm not quite sure
what part of england i was thinking
about
i'm not sure i'm selling england
particularly well yeah it was
eye-watering that's all i remember
so there you go look hold on
so those bits
i mean it's it's thingy bits it's
slippery but those are the
those
it got you yeah papa so he got stung by
a jellyfish and i've seen it in movies
before where if somebody gets stung by a
jellyfish you have to pee on them here
you go look this is so inappropriate by
the way let's see if i have b first of
all mel b
what an amazing lady with a true life
story you know her journey has been
incredible i admire her tenacity and
spirit so much but we were in wales in
the uk swimming ashore and i got stung
by a jellyfish and you can see the rash
just came up on on my arm and then mel
saw it and she instantly went do you
need me to pee on you
are you ready i hasten to add the more
research is done into this the more
tenuous this is but certainly back then
it was something you know i'd grown up
with was always like my dad always
telling me if you get sung by jellyfish
pee in it mel b knew that she said i'll
help i'll pee on it i just never get her
grabbing my hand
and squatting down
and peeing on my hand if you just relax
then i'll relax i've got stage fright i
can't relax
did it help
not really apart from um it made us both
laugh i mean the thing is it did
actually take away a little bit of the
sting but i don't know whether that was
just sort of warm spice girl urine there
you go
don't say i don't do anything for you
you don't always get every guest be
willing to do crazy things all the time
and mel was of that spirit of like come
on let's try it we'll do it so uh thank
you mel
that one is in here and in here
unforgettable
okay so this feels suspiciously like
jumping out of the plane yeah here we go
okay so we gotta go at the same time yep
there we go right so
maybe not too much at the same time so
we don't rag each other normally with
running wild the guys i'm taking are
rookies they might be hollywood
superstars as amazing sportsmen but in
terms of survival and wilderness
adventure they're often rookies which
means you know it's very much kind of
case so i've got the coil of rope and
the compass and come we go together but
we're going this way alex is obviously a
different beast in the sense that he's
probably one of the greatest climbers
that's ever lived he didn't need any
guiding this part of the journey we were
crossing this gorge on the suspension
wires we didn't want to cross the whole
thing i actually wanted to get down into
the gorge but there was nothing really
solid or good to tie off to on the edges
so i thought let's go to the middle
we'll tie the rope drop it and we'll
just free rappel straight down the
middle three two one see ya
it was interesting because you know
here's a guy so fearless but so fearless
within his zone you know and i think his
zone is he's always on the rock and i
think for this when we we did a counter
balance so the rope just went over the
top and you've got to go at the same
time otherwise you know you've got to
make sure simultaneous and he was going
oh wow it's a long way down you know and
i think it's so funny for even someone
like the great alex honold you know when
you look into
free space with nothing tangible there's
no rock next to you
it's a different dynamic it was
heartening to see just a flicker of
flicker of kind of nerves for a second
with him yeah what a good guy
and you see all of the blood coming out
of his jugular there and that really in
an emergency survival situation
is food and life
you know survival is never pretty this
was in siberia in wintertime we were
with the tuva tribesmen up there who are
nomadic indigenous people up in that
part of russia
a hard life you know sub-zero
for a lot of the year crazy wins and
they you know they live off the land
but obviously a big beast like yak is
incredibly valuable for them they don't
want to be killing a yak for for meat
unless it's old and it's on the way out
you know their staple way of doing it is
that they will cut into the carotid
artery here and they have almost like a
tap on it where they can plug it
and they can just
release that clot they can fill up some
jars and stuff with blood but if you're
in an emergency situation
blood is absolutely
right up there in terms of survival food
maybe after liver but blood is just it's
warm it's nutritious got all the amino
acids all the protein all the energy the
salts you need
warm salty
but if you hadn't eaten
came across this this literally would
save you
i think with uh so much of food there's
always a connection with people when you
eat together certainly in terms of
survival i think it's the same and in
terms of indigenous cultures when you
share something that's important and
almost has a spiritual element to them
you create connections i definitely
notice afterwards big smiles on a lot of
the you know indigenous folk and you
know as far as i can i suppose you're
part of the family sharing sharing the
blood uh but they're amazing guys and
always so hospitable and kind to to me